in this video you're going to learn how
to work with the sum and difference
formulas for sine cosine and tangent
we're going to go through six examples
together to find exact values of trig
functions of angles that we don't know
from our unit circle but we can use the
angles that we do know on our unit
circle so let's dive into this video the
first thing we want to do is let's go
ahead and find the sine of 75 degrees so
when we go to our unit circle we say 75
degrees that's not on the unit circle
how do I find the sine of 75 degrees
well that's where these formulas come
into play they're called sum and
difference formulas and what you can do
is you can add or subtract two angles
that you're familiar with here on the
unit circle to find the sine of an angle
that you're not familiar with so what
you want to ask yourself what two angles
add or subtract to 75 degrees well we
could do 45 plus 30 degrees and then
what these formulas are they're like
identities the left side and the right
side are identical so what we're going
to do is we're going to expand to the
right side of the equation here so for
example sine of 75 that's like we said
45 plus 30 or we could do the reverse 30
plus 45. now notice here that our a
value is 45 and our B value is 30 so
when we expand to the right side of our
equation here it's going to be sine of a
which is 45
times the cosine of B which is 30.
plus the cosine of a which is 45
times the sine of B which is equal to
30. okay so now that we've expanded
let's go to our unit circle and say
what's the sine of 45 degrees well 45
degrees remember on the unit circle the
sine is the y coordinate the cosine is
the X so the sine of 45 that's going to
be root 2 over 2.
the cosine of 30 degrees now cosine is
our x coordinate so that's going to be
square root 3 over 2
the cosine of 45 that's our x coordinate
here square root 2 over 2.
and then the sine of 30 that's going to
be our y coordinate at 30 degrees that's
one half
okay so now all we have to do is a
little bit of arithmetic here multiply
the numerators together square root of 2
times square root of 3 is square root of
6. 2 times 2 is 4.
here multiply the numerators together
square root of two times one is square
root of 2 and 2 times 2 is 4. now notice
we have a common denominator of four so
we can combine this into one fraction
square root of 6 Plus square root of 2
over 4 and what this represents it's
like an exact value for the sine of 75
degrees now you could go to your
calculator and type in sine of 75
degrees and you're going to get a
decimal but this is going to be an exact
value now one quick pointer here notice
how I've condensed these formulas like I
put the sine sum formula where you're
adding two angles and the sine
difference formula where you're
subtracting two angles together so if
you notice here we're adding so here
you're adding if you're subtracting
you're subtracting sometimes students
get confused when it comes to cosine
when you're adding you're actually going
to subtract see how that addition signs
on top subtraction sign is on top but
when you're subtracting with cosine then
over here on the right side you're going
to add so it's the opposite so we're
going to work through some more examples
let's look at example number two okay
for example number two now we've got the
cosine of 13 pi over 12. now again we
don't know where 13 pi over 12 is on our
unit circle so we're going to want to
try to find two angles that add or
subtract to give us 13 pi over 12. now a
lot of us are not so familiar in terms
of thinking in terms of radians so what
you might want to do is look at this 13
pi over 12 maybe go over here to the
side and let's convert it into degrees
so remember when you convert from
Readings and degrees you're going to
multiply by 180 degrees for every Pi
radians this way the pi radians in the
numerator cancels with the pi radians in
the denominator later you can also cross
reduce here 12 goes in here once 12 goes
into 180 15 times and then 13 times 15
is
195 degrees
okay so now what two angles add or
subtract to 195 degrees well we could do
150 which we know on our unit circle and
45 those add to 195. so let's go ahead
and rewrite this let's say the cosine of
plus 45
and then notice that a is 150 and B is
45 we're going to go to our cosine sum
formula this is the top one and we're
going to do the cosine of a plus b so
this is going to be the cosine of 150
times the cosine of B which is 45
minus remember it's the opposite if you
add here you're going to subtract with
cosine the sine of 150
times the sine of 45. okay so now back
to our unit circle cosine of 150 150 is
right here cosine's the x coordinate
that's going to be a negative square
root of 3 over 2.
the cosine of 45 that's our x coordinate
at 45 that's going to be square root 2
over 2
and the sine of 150 that's going to be
our y coordinate at 150 that's a half
and the sine of 45 that's our y
coordinate at 45 that's square root 2
over 2. okay now all we have to do is a
little bit of arithmetic so multiplying
the numerators together we get negative
square root of 6. over the denominators
multiplied together which is four
and then here multiply the numerators
together square root of 2 and 2 times 2
is 4. now again notice we have a common
denominator of four so let's go ahead
and combine this
into one fraction
with that common denominator so here we
can see we've got negative square root
of 6 minus square root of 2 all over 4.
and when you're doing these problems a
lot of times you'll notice you get a lot
of square root of sixes and square root
of twos but sometimes you're adding
sometimes you're subtracting sometimes
they're positive sometimes they're
negative
but again keep in mind this is an exact
value for the cosine of 13 pi over 12
which is an angle that we don't know on
our unit circle but we can get from
adding or subtracting two angles that we
do know so let's take a look at another
example for example number three we've
got the tangent of 285 degrees which
again that's not an angle that we're
familiar with on the unit circle but are
there two angles that add to 285 or
subtract to 285 that's the question
right
so you can do two angles that add or
subtract in this case let's go ahead and
do two angles that subtract since we've
been been doing a couple where they add
so in this case you could do uh
315 degrees minus 30 degrees okay that's
the same as 285 so now we're going to go
to our tangent difference formula notice
this is the one here on the bottom and
we're going to expand that to the right
side of our identity so a is going to be
315 and B is going to be 30. so let's
start off with the tangent of 315
degrees
minus the tangent of 30. divided by 1
plus
the tangent of 315 times the tangent of
30. okay tangent of 315. now on the unit
circle the tangent's the y coordinate
divided by the x coordinate so at 315 a
negative root 2 over 2 divided by a
positive root 2 over 2 that's going to
give us a negative 1. so let's replace
that with negative one the tangent of 30
is again the Y over the X so one-half
divided by square root 3 over 2 that's
going to come out to square root 3 over
when you simplify
okay and then let's go to the
denominator the tangent of 315 we
already established that was negative
one and the tangent of 30 we already
established was square root 3 over 3.
now all we have to do is a little bit of
arithmetic so let's simplify a little
bit here so this is going to give us
let's see
negative 1 minus square root of 3 over 3
divided by 1
minus square root of 3 over 3
and what we can do is we can multiply
the numerator and denominator by 3 to
clear the denominator so what we're
going to do is I'm going to distribute
this 3
and I'm going to distribute this 3
and so that's going to give us a
negative 1 times 3 is a negative 3 here
I'll put it over here
and then here are three and the three
that cancels that just gives us a
negative square root of 3. and in the
denominator we have 3 and then here
these threes cancel so we get minus
square root of 3. okay now you could
leave it like that and a lot of times
teachers will be okay with that because
we cleared the complex fraction we don't
have like a fraction inside of a larger
fraction
but technically speaking you don't want
this radical here in the denominator so
we want to rationalize the denominator
by multiplying by the conjugate so here
we've got 3 minus root 3. let's multiply
by 3 plus square root of 3
to the numerator and the denominator
okay so let's go ahead and do this we've
got negative 3 times 3 which is negative
9. negative 3 times square root of 3 is
negative 3 square root of 3 a negative
square root of 3 times 3 is another
negative 3 square root of 3 and negative
square root of 3 times positive square
root of 3 is negative square root of 9
which is just going to give us negative
and in the denominator what happens the
inside and the outside cancel because we
have a negative 3 root 3 and a positive
3 root 3. so the first terms 3 times 3
is 9 and the last terms is going to give
us negative 3. so now let's see negative
9 minus 3 is negative 12. negative 3
root 3 minus 3 root 3 is negative 6
square root of 3. and 9 minus 3 is equal
to 6. okay now what we can do is we can
actually split this up into two
fractions and divide both these terms in
the numerator by 6. so if we do that
that's going to give us negative 12 over
6 which is negative 2 and negative 6
root 3 divided by 6 is just going to
give us negative square root of 3 and
now what we have is an exact value for
the tangent of 285 degrees
okay we're gonna go through three more
examples and I'd like for you to try to
pause the video and do these next three
examples on your own for some practice
and we'll go through them together I
also want to let you know if you like
the way that I explain things and you
want to go deeper with me into like an
Algebra 2 slash college algebra class
I've got a video course for sale that
goes through about 85 lessons it takes
you step by step through a typical
Algebra 2 college algebra course so
check that out in the description below
and if you just want to support the
videos that I'm putting up here on my
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
consider joining and becoming a channel
member so for a few dollars a month you
can help support the channel I see
everybody's name or handle or YouTube
channel or YouTube name that comes
through and I know that you're part of
the channel and I really appreciate that
so let's dive into these last three
examples how would you calculate the
sine of 15 we want an exact value for
the sign of 15. so go ahead and see if
you can do that one now
I'm going to go ahead and use the
identity here and I'm going to think two
angles that add or subtract to 15. well
I could do a sine of
45 minus 30. 45 minus 30 gives us 15.
that's identical and then in our formula
our 45 degrees is our a and our 30 is
our B and we're using the bottom one
here with sine now sometimes uh the way
I learned it originally was sine is the
same meaning if you add it's the same
you add if you subtract you subtract
it's the same whereas cosine it's the
opposite so if you add you subtract
subtract you add that's just a little
hack to help you remember so let's go
ahead and expand this the sine of 45
times the cosine of 30
minus the cosine of 45 times the sine of
30. okay so what's the sine of 45 that's
our y coordinate on our unit circle
which is going to be square root 2 over
2. and you can see there's a lot of
moving Parts in these problems these are
good problems for for teachers to give
because you have to know the unit circle
you have to know your identities you
have to know how to work with radicals
now the cosine of 30 that's the x
coordinate at 30 because cosine's the X
so that's square root 3 over 2
the cosine of 45 that's our x coordinate
at 45 that's root 2 over 2 and the sine
of 30 that's our y coordinate at 30
which is one half
so back to our arithmetic now we've got
multiply the numerators together that's
square root of six denominators together
that's four
multiply the numerators together that's
square root of 2 and the denominators
together that's four common denominator
so we can combine this into one fraction
with that common denominator
square root of 6 minus square root of 2
all over four and again that's an exact
value for the sine of 15 degrees let's
take a look at another example
okay how would you do example number
five we've got cosine of 7 pi over 12.
go ahead and pause the video now if I
was going to do this problem myself I
would convert the 7 pi over 12 into
degrees since I'm not so familiar with
radians uh in terms of figuring out what
two angles add to 7 pi over 12. so over
here on the side let's just go ahead and
do a little conversion we know there's
180 degrees for every Pi radians this
way the pi is in the numerator and
denominator cancel 12 goes into 180 15
times and 7 times 15 is 105 degrees over
1 which is 105. so now a little bit
simpler what two angles add to 105 or
subtract to 105 well we could do 60 plus
45 okay or here let's write that down so
plus 45
sometimes teachers will be real
particular and they'll say well if I
give it to you in radians I want you to
work in radians so what I would do is
instead of using 60 and 45 I would just
say well I know 60 is pi over 3 and I
know 45 is pi over 4 and we'll just work
with the Radian
you know measurements here so let's go
ahead and expand this now notice this is
a cosine sum formula remember how we
said cosine is the opposite so we're
going to subtract on the right so this
is going to be cosine of a
times cosine of B
opposite so subtraction the sine of a
times the sine of B okay so now we just
have to figure out what's the cosine of
pi over 3 cosines are x coordinate at pi
over 3 that's going to be one half
what's the cosine of pi over 4 that's
going to be our x coordinate at pi over
4 which is root 2 over 2.
what's the sine of pi over 3 that's the
y coordinate square root 3 over 2
and what's the sine of pi over 4 that's
the y coordinate square root 2 over 2.
okay so a little bit arithmetic so we've
got numerators multiplied together
that's square root of two denominators
multiplied together that's four
numerators multiplied together that
square root of six denominators
multiplied together that's four
common denominator of four so let's go
ahead and write this as one fraction
with that common denominator and you got
it again this is an exact value for the
cosine of 7 pi over 12. let's go through
one last example okay for our last and
final example we're going to try to
figure out the tangent of 165 degrees
see if you can pause the video and do
this one on your own and let me know in
the comments if you made it all the way
to this final example great job so how
would you do this one tangent of 165
well I tend to think about two angles
that add to 165 but you can do adding or
subtracting in this case what's jumping
out at me is that a 120
plus 45
is equal to 165 so I'm going to work
with 120 plus 45. now we're working with
the tangent sum formula so we're going
to want to use these signs that are up
top here so see up top so now this is
going to come out to the tangent of 120
plus the tangent of 45
divided by 1 minus
the tangent of 120 times the tangent of
45. okay so going to our unit circle now
tangent of 120 remember tangent is the Y
divided by the X so root 3 over 2
divided by negative one half is going to
simplify to negative square root of 3.
the tangent of 45 that's going to be y
divided by X so root 2 over 2 divided by
root 2 over 2 which is 1. and in the
denominator the tangent of 120 we said
was negative root 3 and the tangent of
45 we said was 1. so if we simplify this
let's go ahead and do it over here this
comes out to negative square root of 3
plus 1.
over 1 this is negative root 3 so 1
minus negative root 3 is like 1 plus
square root of 3. and then we want to
rationalize the denominator because we
don't want this radical in the
denominator so we're going to multiply
by the conjugate which is 1 minus square
root of 3. of course whatever we do to
the denominator we want to do to the
numerator okay to keep it balanced so
let's go ahead and multiply these out so
negative root 3 times 1 is negative
square root of 3 negative square root of
3 times negative square root of 3 is
positive 3.
1 times 1 is 1 and 1 times negative root
3 is negative square root of 3 and the
denominator the inside and outside
cancel because that's root 3 and
negative root 3 which is 0. so we're
left with 1 times 1 which is 1 and
negative root 3 times positive 3 is
negative 3. remember when you multiply a
square root times itself you just get
the number underneath but we had a
positive times a negative so it's a
negative
and 1 minus 3 we know is negative two
one plus three is four and negative root
3 plus negative root 3 is negative two
square root of three and then what we'll
do is we'll split this into two
fractions four divided by negative two
and negative two root 3 divided by
negative two so that comes out to
negative two
and positive square root of 3 and that's
an exact answer for the tangent of 165
degrees so great job if you're able to
get that one and if you want more
practice or want to see more examples
follow me to a previous video I did on
the same topic talking about sum and
difference formulas and we'll get some
more practice in that video I'll see
over there